et question 522 de Catherine de roche à
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur
ma question en effet s'adresse à
Monsieur le Ministre d'intérieur sur
l'utilisation de la technique du
crédit-bail par les collectivités
territoriales dans l'intervention
publique locale de l'immobilier
d'entreprise les intercommunalités plus
particulièrement mettent à disposition
des entreprises qui souhaitent
s'installer dans les zones artisanales
intercommunales des bâtiments
industriels au moyen du crédit-bail
cette formule apparaissant comme l'une
des formes juridiques les plus
appropriées en ce domaine or les
conditions réglementaires qui encadrent
l'établissement des crédits immobiliers
se révèlent aujourd'hui assez
restrictive ainsi l'article
l511-5 du Code Monétaire et Financier
précise-t-il que la pratique du
crédit-bail immobilier ne doit pas
revêtir un caractère habituel pour toute
personne autre qu'un établissement de
crédit la jurisprudence quant à elle
considère que l'habitude commence dès la
première répétition en conséquence des
collectivités locales peuvent mettre en
œuvre des opérations d'entreprises en
crédit-bail dans le cadre de leur
pouvoir économique ces opérations ne
peuvent avoir un caractère habituel et
doivent donc être pratiqués de manière
occasionnelle au nombre des sanctions
figurent notamment la nullité du contrat
qui peut être invoquée par le crédit
preneur c'est ce qui est arrivé dans mon
département de Maine-et-Loire la
Communauté de Communes Loir et Sarthe
propriétaire de 12 ateliers relais dont
8 loués en crédit-bail et deux en beaux
courte durée à transformer à l'échéance
soit en crédit-bail soit en bail
commercial c'est vu opposer la nullité
de plusieurs contrats en raison du
caractère répétitif de cette pratique
permettant ainsi au crédit preneur
d'éviter de payer les préavis et les
indemnités dues en cas de résiliation
anticipée il en résiste une il en
résulte une véritable insécurité
juridique pour les collectivités locales
alors même que ces opérations fait
l'objet délibération
vraiment pas reçu la moindre observation
de la part des services de l'État aussi
j'aimerais savoir si le Gouvernement
entend prendre des mesures pour aménager
la pratique du crédit-bail immobilier
cette piste mérite en effet d'être
explorée tant pour permettre aux
intercommunalités d'exercer plus
sereinement leur compétences de
développement économique que pour
répondre à la carence des opérateurs
privés qui n'investissent pas forcément
dans le milieu rural je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice voilà une question qui relève
autant de Manuel Valls d'ailleurs que de
la ministre délégué chargé de la
décentralisation et qui effectivement
pourrait répondre à une vraie
préoccupation vous l'avez rappelé le
contrat de crédit-bail immobilier et
défini comme vous l'avez dit par
l'article l3137 alinéa 2 du code
monataire et financier c'est une
opération par laquelle le crédit
bailleur donne en location pour une
certaine durée un bien immobilier à un
crédit preneur l'entreprise qui aura la
faculté de devenir propriétaire de ce
bien à l'expiration du contrat de
crédit-bail ou par une levée de l'option
d'achat pour un prix fixé
contractuellement le crédit bail
consiste donc en une location
assortie d'une promesse unilatérale de
vente alors ce mode de financement des
investissements à moyen ou leur terme
est assimilé à une opération de crédit
par l'article L313-1 du Code monétaire
financier et à ce titre ne peut être
effectué à titre habituel que par des
entreprises commerciales agréés en
qualité d'établissement de crédit et
c'est l'application de l'article l5152
du code monétaire et financier à titre
exceptionnel et lorsque l'intérêt local
exige les collectivités territoriales et
leurs groupements peuvent déroger au
principe du monocole du monopole
bancaire reconnu aux établissements de
crédit et effectuer des opérations de
crédit-bail en vue d'assurer le
développement ou le maintien d'activité
économique mais vous l'avez rappelé
cette possibilité ne doit pas revêtir un
caractère habituel Maine-et-Loire 8
crédit-bail vous l'avez dit madame la
sénatrice étant observée que la juridisc
la jurisprudence interprète cette notion
de façon très restrictive puisqu'il est
en général considéré que l'habitude
commence dès la première répétition
c'est à dire le deuxième crédit-bail les
collectivités territoriales et leurs
groupements disposent toutefois dans le
cadre de l'article 1511.3 du code
général des collectivités territoriales
de la faculté d'intervenir indirectement
dans une opération de crédit-bail en
accordant des aides à l'immobilier
d'entreprise simplement dans des
conditions très précises c'est l'article
R15 de ce code qui permet d'attribuer
des aides par l'intermédiaire par
l'intermédiaire d'un tiers maître
d'ouvrage habilité à effectuer des
opérations de crédit à titre habituel et
c'est à se mettre de vache de répercuter
intégralement sous forme de rabais sur
les annuités de crédit-bail payé par
l'entreprise l'aide donne alors lieu à
l'établissement d'une convention vous
comprendrez madame récréatrice quand que
dans ces conditions là le respect de la
loi s'impose
merci madame de roche
merci Madame la Ministre alors loin de
moi l'idée de ne pas respecter la loi
mon objectif était de vous sensibiliser
justement aux difficultés rencontrent
les intercommunalités lors de ce
crédit-bail donc ma question s'adressait
est-ce qu'il y a des possibilités
d'améliorer les textes de façon à avoir
un peu plus de souplesse on le sait bien
la situation économique du de la France
est catastrophique à l'inquiète au plus
haut titre et les Français les chefs
d'entreprise mais aussi les élus locaux
et on sait bien que dans la guerre que
nous devons mener contre contre le
chômage et contre toutes les
dégradations d'emploi avec toutes leurs
conséquences sociales voir sociétale je
pense qu'on peut on peut imaginer des
des méthodes et des modifications qui
permettraient libérer les énergies et de
supprimer beaucoup de freins à la
création d'emploi
merci question 543 de Monsieur